all right
[Music]
foreign
uh let's say let's say he's gonna throw
a jab and he's gonna throw a jab at me
okay so uh kimazubi is throws his jab I
follow that jab back in
right right
you have kimosubi here too and the Hand
goes up I have to follow it up
so if we have these drills here
right we're here like that
and uh his hands are on my hand
ready put your hand on Minecraft okay
um
and he brings his hand up into showman
you see
he goes up and I follow it up
goes up that's not kimasubi okay
and uh I'm on this side
okay in my forms
and he's gonna sugiyashi to the rear to
free his sword with Kitty guy
you see ready so he goes up
this is not Ki Mississippi
he goes and stay with it and it goes
right does not lose connection you see
that we'll do it again so you can see
so I have the IP adhesion he goes I keep
the ik adhesion and I go to the next
Ikea teaching connection point
got it okay so uh we're here if this is
too late
here's why move with him
I'll move with him
we do the other side I move with him
I've moved with him
I enter with him
endure with him
enter with him okay every single time
if I'm late
you're going to clash it's gonna come
down
if you can touch his wrist
got it do you see
you caught it coming down because the
hand
I can't touch this
you see I can't touch his wrist okay
so I'd like for you to use
concept of key machine
the
physiological index point I can't touch
his wrist
and therefore my hands go here
right here
so the tegatana is on the tricep tendon
of insertion
on the other hand is just North of it
towards the shoulder okay
then his energy is going to come down
now
when his energy comes down where do you
think that goes anyone can answer
where am I going to take it
into a rotation nope that's your problem
I'm not going to take it into a rotation
okay the first thing I do he goes cool
and I'm going to project do you see and
I'll project him look look at where we
are now do you see if the camera comes
over there
where do you go
he's off the line and now I can enter
here it's ever so it's not an external
thing it becomes an extra little thing
after the projection okay
so I'm going to come around and bring
the camera back around over to this side
it is his hands coming down I started to
rotate
this half will come
from the ticketana around
just below the elbow because again I
can't reach that okay just below the
elbow and now it's trapped in here
push
pull on the circle boom
[Music]
here
so I would do it again and you'll watch
for that I love with him there's a
tricep tentative insertion he props down
boom I move that over I come around
there it is right there
boom
and again I'm at the end
so do it again team assuming around
okay misumi
cool
[Music]
get those hand placements please go
okay uh my last point was don't don't
make it into a leverage technique so I'm
not gonna go here and then I push pull
do you see
do this that's not what I'm doing the
only goal of this Push Pull is to stop
his hand from posting
so it doesn't it's not a huge lever it
doesn't require much of an engine
you've seen he'll reach for the ground
but I keep bringing it around
foreign
comes around and I just don't want his
hand to post
you see that I can't get his wrist again
if you're gaming it and your UK is not
throwing a stride you can grab his wrist
but it's full speed his wrist will not
be there his his arm goes into the cut
do you see so all you have is this and
all you need to do is keep this hand
from posting
that's it
so as I go that's all I'm doing
this hand is doing the technique
this time but he'll post on you
sure
okay let's try it again
okay we gotta go back to the test sabaki
okay so uh
this this hand right here right this is
the key machine behind his hand goes up
to his head and I follow it up okay
but that hand that hand correct that
hand is actually uh yo
there's only
uh there's only the fire Spyro and then
the water spider
that's all I have okay so when his hand
goes up
you have the inward spiral it just stops
at the top and then heals okay
and then uh my outward spiral do you
think
so these two hands meet right Fire and
Water right there you see that
so this this hand
because it is
The Perennial philosophy
from another point of view
that is also the fire hand
can you see it if he stands up and grabs
me with his left hand
sorry right hand you see this is it
right there
do you see that can you see that
so it's both fire and water is going at
the same time
see so to do those hands it's not here
do you see that wrist that that's not
correct
this wrist has to spiral into its
pattern
this isn't it either
boom here
so okay now I'm here now I have a
different relationship with him and now
as I come around I don't want to go here
that's what you're doing you see my
elbow on this this side right here okay
what I do instead is just blend blend
blend until your hand falls because it's
gonna fall because you're striking and
then I right there
you guys see that
so hold some of your weird shapes this
this
those those aren't your shapes you'll
you only have you only have that inner
circle and the outward
okay
so he is
can you see it okay and then I move
until his hand gets
to that opening I take the opening at
his hand gate
I don't go and actively seek it
boom his hands dropping it drops into my
other hand again
who says dropping it drops into the
other half
so first fix how you make contact and
then be patient let it go till it's a
natural movement and not you going over
the top okay
try it again